mais voyez plutôt ce reportage sont les
préparatifs réalisé avec charlie fief et
sa belle faut qu une heure avant le
concours enfin de ja frais est aux
petits soins
un dur un essai 1400 kg un taureau de
race rouge des prés est préparé pour son
entrée sur le grand ring
donc là je rentre un avec de la laque
donc de remontrer le poil de montauroux
à en rire dresse ça fait toujours plus
jolie le jeune homme de 18 ans élève au
lycée agricole de bourges vient au salon
depuis ses 6 ans il connaît les critères
de notation de son taureau parker ça
sera sur la morphologie de la bête la
grandeur la hauteur c'est à plomb s'il
marche bien
son art on lit pilote salines de 2 c'est
une bonne ligne de dos une bonne
rectitude ça c'est les critères
principaux et après quand les bêtes sont
en liga vraiment égalité on va chercher
vraiment effectif les petits défauts de
razz antoinette assisté de son père et
de son grand-père
ces éleveurs du loir et cher sont des
habitués du concours général
inimaginable pour eux de manquer une
édition du salon de l'agriculture -
rennes c'est déjà une bonne chose mais
pour moi la satisfaction d'avoir un fils
un petit fils
la ferme n'a pas de prix d'abord parce
que tu vas voir mieux
on a commencé à venir ici c'est vital
demir régulièrement c'est bien d'y venir
tous les ans après une année on il n'ya
pas les clients nous oublie il faut
recommencer à zéro et locale ils ont
l'habitude on arrive à fidéliser la
clientèle
autres races à viande autre concours
johnny le charolais a terminé cinquième
dans sa catégorie ce qui est singulier
ce n'est pas son palmarès mais c'est son
gène c'est le premier tour ou charolais
sans cornes à concourir au salon
l'intérêt en termes de sécurité c'est à
dire que l'animal il a pas de cornes
donc c'est moins dangereux pour
l'éleveur le deuxième élément c'est pour
le bien-être animal c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas de l'opération des cordages et
troisième élément
sachez que dans les pays de l'est ce
qu'ils ont des troupeaux de 500 de
millevaches s'il fallait qu'ils ses
cordes
il prendrait ça prendrait un temps fou
l'intérêt pour les bovins sont cornes
augmente les délégations allemandes et
danoises sont intéressés par ce
reproducteurs helvea les autres atouts
brain dans l'indre ces semences aux
normes internationales donc le but mon
nous c'est de valoriser
des paillettes qui a entre autres un des
moyens ces deux d'être présent au salon
agricole de paris et de le faire
participer à un événement international
quatre mille doses de semence du taureau
ont été prélevés la moitié de la
descendance de johnny ne sera pas cornu
l'autre moitié le sera